-(BIRD COOING)
-(OMINOUS SILENCE)
♪ ("SONG OF A SINNER"
BY TOP DRAWER PLAYING) ♪
♪ How can you keep me ♪
♪ Knowing I've made you
Sadly ♪
Can you handle
more amazing news?
♪ And yet
I ask to be forgiven ♪
♪ Knowing the life
That I've been living ♪
BARRY BERKMAN: We've both done
terrible things in our lives,
but everybody deserves
a second chance.
I believe that you can be
the version of yourself
that you wanna be.
I need a purpose.
Forgiveness is something
that has to be earned.
It's like that line
in Shawshank Redemption,
"Get rich or die trying."
BARRY: If I don't do this,
I don't live!
I have to do this to live!
(SCREAMING)
When I met Mr. Cousineau,
I was a lost soul.
He didn't just teach me
how to be a better actor,
he taught me how to be
a human being.
He saved my life.
-You look good.
-So do you.
-I'm, like, legit nervous.
-If we don't hear from you
in two hours,
we will all take cyanide pills.
-What?
-Ciao, babies.